Wealthy corporations and people love to
ask the question,
what can I do?
What should we do?
What can we start?
What program could we launch?
I would say to the billionaire,
change agents and corporate corporate
social responsibility departments of our
country.
Ask not what you can do for your
Ask what you've already done to your
country.
Okay?
Before you want to start something of
your own little private,
unaccountable venture.
Do an audit.
What do you pay people.
You pay people enough?
Do you use subcontractors to avoid
responsibility for those workers?
Do you pay benefits?
When do your benefits kick in?
What do you lobby for in Washington?
Do you lobby for things that
make everybody have a better life in
America or do lobby against social
policies that would cost you something?
What's your tax avoidance situation?
Are you,
do you happen to be this ernest company
that,
that that wants to change the world?
I mean this is this,
is this company paying its full measure
of taxes?
Does it use tax havens?
Does it do the double Dutch with an
Irish Sandwich tax maneuver?
Does it send money that came in islands
and then back and do all this complex
routing.
If you're telling me that there are
companies that do none of this stuff
that pay people well,
that don't dump externalities into the
economy,
that don't cause social problems.
If there is such companies exist.
Yeah.
Then once you've taken care of all that,
great,
doing some some projects to help people
is great,
but I haven't found very many such
companies and more often than not,
when companies do a lot of CSR,
it's because they understand that
they're not on the right side of justice
in their day operations.
So they want to do virtual as a side
hustle.
And the problem is a lot of these
companies tend to create harm in
billions and then do good in the
millions and you don't need to be a
mathematician to know that we're the
losers from that bargain.
And you'd look at the b Corp Movement,
there's a lot of companies that actually
have an interest in trying to invent a
new kind of company that is not
predatory.
There's in the B Corp Movement,
a certification process for those
companies.
Now the challenges of them is that it's
a great thing,
but it's fundamentally voluntary.
And what this does is it means that if
you're,
you know,
on already good virtuous company,
you may be motivated to get into this
club,
but if you're Exxon or Pepsi,
um,
you know,
you're not gonna,
you're not going to be in this club.
One of the things I'd like to see is how
can we actually use the power of public
policy to get more companies to sign up
to simply not dump harm,
social harm into our society.
Whether that takes the form of toxic
sludge or obese children or,
uh,
workers with unpredictable hours and
income.
And in the B Corp,
we have a model of a company that looks
different,
but we don't have any kind of compulsion
around it.
So,
you know,
Senator Elizabeth Warren has a proposal
out to turn every American Corporation
to a b Corp as a condition for,
um,
getting a corporate charter.
I think there's less radical option that
I sometimes talk about,
which is why don't we just have a
different and lower corporate tax rate
for companies that in a certifiable way
don't dump huge social problems onto the
Commons.
Um,
and that that way we might see thousands
and thousands of companies electing to
become,
you know,
certified benefit corporations,
uh,
in order to avail of that lower tax
rate.
I think we have to start thinking about
how we attack one of the root causes of
this kind of,
um,
grading malfeasance in American life,
which is shareholder primacy and the
fact that many companies,
even ones that want to be better,
are at risk of violating their
shareholders' rights by doing so.
But I don't think we can do that
strictly by creating a voluntary,
uh,
pool of better companies.
I think we have to start using our
leverage of society to say,
if you want the benefits that we as a
society give you when you become a
corporation,
here's what we want in return.